the world's religions are beginning to
develop an ecological theology to help
solve the global environmental crisis
Mary Evelyn Tucker and John Grimm
founders of the forum on religion and
ecology at Yale say the world is
witnessing the emergence of a new
religious consciousness that considers
the natural world sacred in probably the
most profound way the religious
traditions for millennia have offered to
humans away a sustaining life in the
midst of tremendous suffering of despair
of a sense of tragedy of facing death
and for some people they would say we
are facing the death of life we are
facing the extinction of species at
twenty and thirty thousand species a
year this has never happened for 65
million years when the dinosaurs were
extinct by an asteroid made extinct so
what does this mean for humans to draw
in a sense that we are altering the life
systems of the planet the air the water
the soils the prospect for food to feed
this number of people that we've
exploded to over six billion people hope
is I think at this moment eluding us in
many ways and yet I do think that if we
can generate the possibilities that
humans have created civilization and
culture over centuries and at this
moment the most crucial thing is that we
can create a sustainable multiform
multi-religious planetary civilization
that says this is one planet we are one
species and we have got to find our role
as humans amidst a larger Earth
community that that's the hope and
actually I think
the excitement about this is that
there's a great work to be done there's
all kinds of work within economics and
technology and politics to make this
actually happen and that's the
empowerment for humans who fundamentally
want to make a difference for the future
in the their deepest aspirations for
their children for their children's
children people are willing to make
sacrifices if they're asked for the
right reasons and that I think tension
between hope and sacrifice and
possibility for a flourishing future is
what religious sensibilities can offer
professors Tucker and grim view this new
relationship between religion and
environment as a broad
interdenominational movement not the
province of any one religion something
new is happening it's like a real of
human earth relations I think that's
part of the passion that that moves us
rather than simply one denomination it's
in all of these denominations like
Vatican to this moment in the Catholic
tradition in the 60s where this would
there was this incredible turn to a
state that the Catholic tradition
recognized other religions and they used
the phrase rays of light that they're a
rays of light and other traditions and
our teacher Thomas berry would step back
and pause for a moment he'd say my
goodness rays of light there are floods
of light in these tradition and so what
we're seeing is we undertake this
project is the the floods of
understanding in these traditions the
radiance of these traditions in their
possibility for guiding people into
renewed human earth reflection all of
the religions have begun to develop
statements on the environment they're up
on the website that Yale has now on the
religion and ecology each of the
traditions has worked through their
processes of their own bureaucracy to
say creation is important in fact sacred
and there's issues here of justice for
example
how the poor are going to be affected by
climate change and so on so there are
general statements on the environment
and now we're finding even more specific
programs and campaigns about issues like
the climate change and global warming
for example there's a very large project
called interface power and light based
in California but involving now over
twenty two states and four thousand
projects of churches and synagogues
involved with examining their energy use
so it's a response to climate change and
changing light bulbs and so on but
raising consciousness it as well it's
been extremely effective the
evangelicals have gotten on board for
climate change in a major way and
they've begun to partner with scientists
this would have been unheard of even
seven years ago and that happened
because two scientists in Oxford
explained to a group of American
evangelicals just about 25 and the facts
of climate change they heard it from
evangelical scientists very high level
people and they said this is an issue of
justice because the poor are going to be
affected all over the world they already
are in Bangladesh and look what's
happened in in Burma
so the evangelicals feel climate change
is very much about God's creation but
also about the poor and the affect on
the poor for climate change religions
long preoccupied with personal salvation
re-examining the role of humans in the
natural world one of the central
challenges for religions as they move
into their ecological phase is to
reinvent their earth orientation and
many of the traditions do have an
otherworldly a personal salvation and
obsession with the interior life only of
the human but always balancing that is a
sense in these traditions that humans
are part of a community whether it's
churches or synagogues or mosques and
they are part of a natural system you
can't have these rituals that were based
often on agricultural cycles the harvest
and the solstice and equinox and
all of these rituals are around the
seasons of the day the seasons of the
year traditions have this in their past
and the question is how they bring it
forward I think the world's religions
are beginning to get on the bus to
figure out how to drive it to look at
the window and respond to what
scientists have been saying about
climate change and pollution and the
whole range of issues and just say yes
we have an issue here that we need to
respond to and one of our approaches is
that the religions be the religious
leaders or laypeople they've got to see
themselves as partners with this
tremendous movement that's decades old
already I mean the first environmental
day was in the early 70s so religions
are late but necessary they are not
sufficient but they complete something
and that is this sensibility that humans
come out of natural processes in an
evolutionary sense and we're deeply part
of bio regional systems we depend on air
on water on this interaction of life of
plant life of animal life and so on and
so religions in their cosmologies their
stories of the origin of the universe
and how humans fit into natural systems
are beginning to re and this is a new
moment for examining their stories and
the role of humans in the natural world
all the rituals of world's religions are
very much nature based you can't have a
Eucharist for example in the Christian
tradition without a sense of wheat of
the earth that brings the wheat forward
or the the grapes for the wine and if
the whole system is polluted what does
this mean for a sense of Eucharist a
sense of Thanksgiving what is that bread
actually imply so a new understanding of
sacrament of ritual is emerging in these
traditions because fundamentally these
traditions take nature as sake
nature is a manifestation of creation of
a created order and whether they have
God involved or not the Western
religions do have a sense that this is a
sacred and created order and that were
stewards were trustees of this created
order professors Tucker and Grimm say
that religions are rediscovering their
ancient traditions in response to the
environmental crisis the joint degree
program here at Yale between the school
of Forestry and environmental studies
and the Divinity School is an academic
approach to the field of religion and
ecology and that means it's
interdenominational it's inter-religious
it's not emphasizing one tradition over
another it's trying to draw on all of
the traditions without idealizing Asian
religions or any any one particular
tradition and that's the excitement that
students can see this objective and yet
engaged study of this conjunction of
religion etiology clearly we're saying
these traditions in their ancient texts
and their scriptures and so on need to
be reconfigured they're not the answers
without rethinking where we are because
they've got to respond to very different
problems than were around when those
scriptures were written but the students
understand as well that there's an
engagement here for transformation of
persons and communities around the world
there's a real possibility in fact even
hope the humanities and the sciences
find common ground in Yale's religion
and ecology program another dimension of
this program that has real traction is
it's a setting in which humanities and
the science are finding a ground for
common dialogue and this is a new and
innovative field where the question of
the humanities and environmental concern
has been unclear and now this area of
values that Mary Ellen has stressed it's
finding a place for investigation in
this type of program but especially the
role of the humanities in this
relationship or what we might say
religions retreated or
the area of cosmology the whole
understanding of what is the world
character of the world it retreated from
that question over five centuries ago
and what we're seeing now I believe is
the re-entry of religion and humanities
broadly speaking into the question of
cosmology this joint program between the
forestry school and Divinity School is
actually the only one of its kind in
North America and in the world so it's
it's really on the edge of a new field
of study that has got tremendous
interest from the students because many
of them have studied abroad especially
in the forestry school and understand
why Buddhism could actually help in the
protection of trees in Thailand and so
on so in the Divinity School students to
really see that religion in responding
to the world at present has to be
involved in ecological issues so the
dynamics in the classroom are absolutely
fascinating between forestry and
environmental study students and the
divinity students I think what's
happening at Yale is unique this program
is an example of that the depth of
exploration that's being undertaken Yale
between the humanities their Sciences
and the Social Sciences and this joint
degree program brings all of those
disciplines to bear it's really a unique
and wonderful time to be at this setting
for more information on the environment
and religion program at Yale University
visit yale.edu slash religion and
ecology for more information about the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies visit environment
Yale dot edu